طبعا لم يكن رد اسرائيلي خلافا لما اوردته
رويترز اسرائيل نفت ان تكون ردت بقذائف
مدفعيه حتى الساعه هذا الرد متوقع بدون ان
شك لكن سيكون هناك اجتماع للحكومه الامنيه
المصغره عند الثامنه والنصف بالتوقيت
المحلي مساء هذا اليوم
ستجتمع الحكومه الامنيه المصغره
لاتخاذ قرار حول طبيعه الرد التقديرات في
اسرائيل بان اسرائيل ليست بصدد ان تخوض
حربا بسبب التطور الذي جرى ولكن سيكون
هناك نوع من الرد قد يكون حتى في اكثر من
جغرافيا بمعنى اسرائيل
يعني تتهم بعناد جهاد فلسطينيه في اخر
الاتهامات وجهت اتهاما لحماس لان هي من
قامت من جنوب لبنان باطلاق رشقات الصواريخ
بالتالي سنرى ردا على الارجح في جنوب
لبنان لان الصواريخ انطلقت من هناك ولكن
من غير مستبعد ان يكون هناك غارات ايضا
على قطاع غزه بسبب انها تتهم حماس او هكذا
ورد بوفقه تسريبات في اسرائيل ايا كان
يبدو ان الامور متوتره جدا لكنها تبقى
قابله للاحتواء بدون كسر قواعد اللعبه لا
من حزب الله ولا من اسرائيل في هذه
المرحله